[Música]
fallecieron al menos 33 personas y hay
al menos 70 desaparecidos en alemania
tras fuertes inundaciones en el
occidente del país las autoridades
evalúan edificios afectados y se esperan
más lluvias en los próximos días en
bélgica también murieron 6 personas
tenemos informe desde berlín
continúo en las protestas contra el
gobierno cubano por tercer día se
manifestaron exiliados anticastristas en
miami
las movilizaciones se vieron en otros
países de la región y desde españa el
gobierno elevó su rechazo también hubo
algunas manifestaciones a favor
y en los deportes etapa 18 de tour de
francia con dos puertos fuera de
categoría y final en alto aunque todo
indica que el esloveno tadej o achares
seguirá vestido de amarillo se espera
una dura batalla por el podio tenemos
información desde pau el sitio de
partida
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y estas son las noticias de france
24 comenzamos el informativo con
información de alemania fallecieron al
menos 33 personas y hay decenas de
desaparecidos o por causa de las fuertes
inundaciones en el occidente del país
las calles se convirtieron en arroyos
fueron arrastrados automóviles y algunos
edificios colapsaron las aguas inundaron
también la ciudad belga de purga tuareg
de cerca de la frontera alemana y hay
seis muertos
vamos a berlín con el reporte de tomas
sparrow
las imágenes de las inundaciones de las
fuertes lluvias y de las tormentas en
particular en el occidente de alemania
están causando cada vez más preocupación
en el país a medida que las autoridades
locales actualizan el número de muertos
el número de desaparecidos e informan
también no solamente sobre las casas que
ya han colapsado sino también sobre los
edificios que están en riesgo la
situación es tan delicada en algunas
zonas que hay distritos que tuvieron que
declarar el estado de emergencia para
permitir que soldados con maquinaria
pesada pudieran llegar a la zona para
ayudar con las labores de rescate y más
importante aún la situación no está del
todo controlada y hay preocupación
especial luego de que el servicio
meteorológico alemán informará que en
especial en el sur occidente del país se
esperan lluvias fuertes este jueves y
posiblemente también el viernes
la unión europea inició acciones legales
contra hungría y polonia por violar los
derechos de la comunidad lgbt y más la
movida es resultado de las leyes
recientemente aprobadas en esos países
el que violan los derechos humanos
reportado desde bruselas esther herrera
la comisión europea ha abierto un
expediente contra las leyes de hungría y
polonia que consideran que discriminan a
la comunidad lgtb y en el caso de
hungría la comisión europea rechaza que
a partir de ahora en las escuelas no se
pueda hablar de sexualidad tampoco se
podrán emitir películas y series de
televisión en horario infantil en que
aparezcan parejas del mismo sexo y
además relaciona de forma velada
pedofilia con homosexualidad si el
gobierno húngaro mantiene esta ley el
caso podría acabar en la justicia
europea aunque esta polémica ley ha
provocado muchísimo rechazo también
entre los diferentes países de la unión
europea en la última reunión de jefes de
estado de gobierno la gran mayoría de
líderes europeos mostraron su rechazo al
primer ministro del país viktor orbán en
el caso de polonia algunos municipios
del país se han declarado zonas libres
de personas lgtb y lo que puede provocar
una clara discriminación por la
orientación sexual de las personas
hungría y polonia mantienen un pulso
desde hace muchos años con la unión
europea por algunos
que vulneran el estado de derecho pero
hasta ahora apenas ha habido
consecuencias por tercer día consecutivo
miami se llenó de banderas cubanas y de
cientos de exiliados que apoyan las
protestas contra el gobierno de miguel
díaz-canel debido a la escasez y al
manejo de la pandemia el descontento se
extendió a otros países del continente y
a españa entretanto el primer ministro
de la isla manuel marrero anunció que se
retiran las restricciones que limitan el
ingreso de comida y medicamentos al
menos hasta el 31 de diciembre
la lluvia caía con fuerza sobre miami
pero no impidió que cientos de
emigrantes cubanos y otras personas
contrarias al gobierno de díaz canel se
reunieran por tercer día consecutivo en
favor de las protestas en la isla
a los 62 años una dictadura y
yo me fui hace siete años
yo en realidad nunca vez de verano
aparecido a lo largo de la manifestación
destacaba el lema patria y vida
contraparte del famoso patria o muerte
que adoptó la revolución liderada por
fidel castro- pedidos también de ayuda
al gobierno estadounidense algunos
incluso apuntan a una intervención
militar
vamos a pedirle sino una intervención lo
que sea pero algo que haga por el juego
una petición que también hicieron
decenas de cubanos desde costa rica
un grupo de personas se manifestó
también en la capital de españa allí
exigieron libertad de expresión y mayor
democracia en cuba durante el miércoles
el presidente español pedro sánchez
afirmó que en la isla no existe
democracia por la noche la comunidad de
madrid' iluminó su sede con la bandera
cubana de calle enorme y es un gesto
precioso de el cual los cubanos estamos
enormemente agradecidos y sólo podemos
decir gracias en buenos aires- la
embajada de cuba se vio rodeada de
manifestantes algunos en contra del
gobierno otros en favor de la soberanía
de la isla y el fin del bloqueo
estadounidense una muestra de la
disparidad de pasiones que levanta la
revolución cubana dentro y fuera del
continente en otras noticias en
lentamente se reduce la violencia en
sudáfrica tras una semana de incendios y
saqueos la razón en varios distritos se
espera la llegada de más soldados a las
calles escenas como las vistas en durban
es donde multitudes arrastraron carros
cargados con harina y otros alimentos
básicos saqueados empezaron a mermar 9
gasolina y grupos de taxistas bloquearon
algunas carreteras
a frenar los robos desencadenados por
las protestas contra la ida a prisión
del ex presidente jacob zuma y en
rechazo a la desigualdad con la mitad de
la población bajo el umbral de la
pobreza
en noticias de kobe 19 con la variante
delta más contagiosa y feroz se plantea
una tercera dosis de la vacuna por el
momento o francia la administra a las
personas inmunodeprimidas israel a los
llamados o frágiles e indonesia al
personal hospitalario pero a nivel
mundial no hay consenso
de la 11 apenas empiece el curso escolar
se pondrá en marcha una campaña de
refuerzo de vacunas sin nombrarla
directamente emanuel macua evoca la
famosa tercera dosis y se destina por el
momento a aquellos que fueron los
primeros en vacunarse las personas
mayores y la población de riesgo todos
aquellos que en las próximas semanas y
meses verán bajar sus niveles de
anticuerpos y disminuir su inmunidad
las citas se podrán agendar a partir de
los primeros días de septiembre en un
momento en que la contagiosa variante
delta está provocando brotes en todo el
mundo surgen argumentos para una tercera
dosis con facer variante que liderando
la defensa de esta inyección según los
laboratorios debería administrarse seis
meses después de la segunda dosis
europa dice estar lista we are over y ya
estamos bien preparados posible
necesitamos eeuu es un poco más
reticente
nos estamos asegurando de tener tantas
opciones sobre la mesa como sea posible
para nosotros
el pueblo estadounidense en israel ya se
decidieron la inyección de una tercera
dosis comenzó para el público llamado
frágil pero el regulador sanitario
internacional ya advirtió que una dosis
adicional no está en la agenda mundial
while men y countries
cuando muchos países ni siquiera han
empezado a vacunar y otros países ya ha
vacunado a la mayoría de su población
con las dos dosis y ahora está pasando a
una tercera dosis que es el refuerzo es
seriamente decepcionante no tiene
sentido los wichis de booster según la o
ms los laboratorios deberían dirigir sus
dosis a los países subdesarrollados que
todavía tienen dificultades para
adquirir y administrar las primeras
dosis como áfrica
finalizamos con información deportiva
hoy es la etapa 18 del tour de francia
la última de alta montaña con dos
puertos fuera de categoría no se esperan
grandes cambios en la general al margen
de lo deportivo fiscales franceses
abrieron una investigación sobre dopaje
contra el equipo bahrein victorious
desde los pirineos franceses en la
ciudad de pago informa en nuestro
enviado especial
luís miguel cabrera
la última disputa por la montaña se
libra hoy en la etapa 18 del tour de
francia un recorrido de 130 kilómetros
entre la ciudad de puno donde me
encuentro y la estación de deportes de
invierno
luz ardiden será un recorrido que se
complejiza 'va a mitad de camino con dos
grandes de los pirineos precisamente el
paso de tumbalá y la propia meta de luz
ardiden será por supuesto una batalla
decisiva para los escaladores aunque es
poco probable que se produzcan cambios
en la clasificación general más allá de
los cinco primeros lugares y como
colofón de esta jornada el propio
presidente emmanuel macrón estará en la
meta para premiar a los ganadores siga
con nosotros esto es france24
[Música]